Selamlar sevgili dostlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir. Ailenizle birlikte
sağlıklı, uzun bir ömür geçirirsiniz
inşallah. Sevdiğiniz ekiplerde
çalışıyorsunuzdur. İş arıyorsanız güzel
iş fsatları sizinledir. Eee umarım yakın
zamanda da yine teknik anlamda
beklentilerinizi karşıladığınız zamanlar
yaşarsınız. Hem yazdığınız prompllarla
hem yapacağınız testlerle. Evet
arkadaşlar master class serisine devam
ediyorum. E master class serisinin hemen
bir öncekinde paket mimarası klasör
yapısını konuşmuş. Şuralarla biraz
incelemiştik. Bugünkü yapacağımız
içerikte de aslında direkt işsue da
oluşturdum. En azından buradan PR
gözüksün diye. E PR
command'i bağlayacağım için burada
gözükecek. Bu arada main dart
düzenlemesi, app setup ve envirment
configuration. Bunlar yine aslında
config olarak daha detaylı
ilerleyeceğimiz noktalar ama mesela bu
tarz bir projede bir başlangıç ve
aslında önemini gösterme anlamında
yapıyor olacağım. ki çünkü eee şurada da
hatta bunun için özel bir ufak bir
notumu da hazırlamış olmuş. Şöyle alayım
bu tarafa. Eee bu tarz projelerde çünkü
arkadaşlar haz run etmek anlamında veya
configleri yapmak anlamında birkaç
noktamız var. Onları ben önceden bir
hazırladım zaten. Onu da size hızlıca
gösteriyor olacağım. Böyle tek tek artık
kodu yazmayacağım. Zaten o dönemde
değiliz artık. Onun için ben de hızlıca
süreci anlatım üzerinden geçmeye
çalışacağım. Şimdi eee ben şeyimi
oluşturmuştum zaten. Envirment
initializer diye burayı oluşturmuştum.
Buraya geldim. Şimdi arkadaşlar genelde
bu tarz projelerde veya böyle şeyin
olmadığı yerlerde böyle bir structor
olmadığı yerlerde veya kaosun başladığı
yerler genelde main dart'ta o zaten
olayı anlıyorsun. Çünkü bilen veya
bilmeyen demeyeyim de genelde bakış
hemen aslında o AI yazılan kodlarda da
doğru yönlendirilmediği sürece doğrudan
Main Dart'ın şu setup kısmı özellikle
çok fazla doldurulup gereksiz veya
ihtiyaç halinde olmayacak şekilde
buralara kodlar dahil oluyor. Burada
önemli olan hareket şu. Bizim iki
noktada kesinlikle hemfikir olmamız
lazım. Main dart normalde aslında future
metod burada mesela gördüğünüz gibi
future bağlanmamış da yani feature bir
nevi işte assing aate koymuş önüne.
Neyse eee beklemesi gereken bir yer
değil aslında aslında şu main direkt
runi çalıştırdığı an uygulama başlamış
demektir. Fakat sen önüne bir katman
eklersen mesela diim feature delay attın
bir şey attın bu uygulamanın start
yapmasını geciktirir. Bu da aslında ne
oluyor? Otomatik olarak splash dediğimiz
ekranlarda uygulama daha çok kalıyor. Bu
noktada en önemli kural önüne
koyacağınız kodlar yani şuradaki
kodların kesinlikle ve kesinlikle
ihtiyaç olanları runap öncesi mesela
Firebase initializları eee size bir
asenkroniste ihtiyaç ihtiyacı olmayan
mesela bir logger paketi olabilir
localization paketi olabilir çeşitli
paketlerin belki küçük küçük
initializerları onlar çok bloklamaz sizi
zaten ama diğer çünkü mesela
localization niye önemli çünkü globalde
olması lazım proje başladığında set
ediyoruz ama mesela Mesela diyelim ki e
normal şartlarda Firebase instance'ından
ya da analitikle alakalı bir logic var.
Şimdi bu analitikle alakalı logicin
bakıldığında illa önce olmasına gerek
yok. Bunun doğru yeri mesela splash
tarafında uygulama başladıktan sonraki
logiclerde belki home sayfasını da
yönetiyor olabilirsiniz arka tarafta. He
şimdi biz bugün ne yapacağız konumuzun
dışına çok çıkmadan biz dedik ki şimdi
main dart'ı düzeltelim. Şimdi abi
diyelim ki siz bu main dart'a girdiniz
ve bu main dart'ın içerisinde de çeşitli
hareketler öncelikle temel mantığımız
zaten ikincisi doğru orantılı bir
initializer logi yazmamız olacak. Bu
bizim hayatımızı kurtaracak. Şimdi ben
öncelikle şu mainta şu eski yerine geri
alacağım. En azından şurada daha güzel
gözüküyor. Alışkanlıktan dolayı da
arkadaşlar
bu arada bir arkadaş da yoruma yazmıştı
abi işte MCP'ler promptlar. Bu zaten
mesela bu içeriğim bittikten sonra size
prompt olarak da vereceğim burada neler
yaptığımızı. fikirleri belki her
paylaştığım içeriği şunları da ondan
paylaşıyorum ki siz de görün diyor. Bu
içerik kısa kısa fikir anlatmak üzerine
öyle çok detaya girip çok size bu işte
şöyle kodu sıfırdan yazmayacağım zaten
ki çünkü amacım o kodu zaten hepimiz
artık üretiyoruz. O üretme yolunda size
o fikri verebilmek ki üretilen koda
yorum yapın veya üretilen fikre neden
diyebileyim veya şunu yapayım
diyebiliniz. Şimdi buraya geldim. Şu
bazı birkaç tane kodu sadece önden
hazırlamadım. Bunları çünkü ufak bir
göstereyim de. Mesela initializer
içerisine ben bir tane app şöyle
application initializer diye bir katman
basitçe yazıyorum. Tamam mı? Inish
inizer.
Şimdi ben bunu buraya atıyorum. Buraya
da bir tane arkadaşlar app
initializer'ımı atıyorum buraya. Şimdi
burada benim önemli olan iki tane
aslında olayım var. Size hatta üç olay
göstereceğim ki bence bunlar önemli.
Şimdi şunları kapatayım. Şimdi burada
benim main Dart'tan önceki yapacağım
işlemlerle main Dart'tan sonraki
yapacağım işlemler farklı aslında
bakıldığında. Yani aslında benim bazı
logiklerim var. Mesela belki şu
logjikten belki şuradan sonra olacak
bundan önce olacak veya bazı
logiklerimin otomatik olarak çağrılması
gerekiyor herhangi bir sınırsı olmadan.
Yani ne demeye çalışıyorum? Mesela şunun
gibi işte ekrandaki çizim için gerekli
olan komponentimiz var diyelim. Tamam
mı? Bu her defasında her projeye
girdiğinde görürsünüz. Bu işte binding
çağırılıyor burada. Bu kendi
initializerlarını çağırıp işte bu
instance'ı kaldırıyorsun. İşte set
olmuyorsa set ediyor. Yoksa onu
döndürüyor gibi görüyorsunuz burada
zaten. Şimdi bunun gibi bazı kodlarımızı
biz aslında diyoruz ki hocam ben burada
bir tane her zaman çalışacağım için bir
tane statik burada bir tane runımı
atayım. Tamam mı? Bu runım benim için
burada gelsin desin ki mesela hocam ne
var senin? Şu widget binding initializer
var. Tamam mı? Bu çünkü senin herhangi
bir şeyle bağı olmayacak. En temiz bir
şekilde direkt doğrudan run olması
gereken. Bu şimdi ilerledikçe siz de
sizin tarafınızda Flatter tarafında
kodlar özellikle daha böyle main dartı
büyük projeler gördüğünüzde zaten bunun
ne olduğunu anlayacaksınız. Çünkü
öncesinde bazı kodlar dediğim gibi bazı
böyle cord şeyler doğrudan çağrılması
gerekiyor herhangi bir katman koymadan.
Şimdi bu AP initializer'ı yazdınız.
Bundan sonraki arkadaşlar logic şöyle
ayrılıyor olması lazım. Bu fikir olarak
hiç böyle uzatmadan böyle yazacağım. Bir
tane abstract class yazacaksınız buraya.
Diyeceksiniz ki eee platform
initializer. Tamam mı? Buraya da mesela
pre diyebilirsiniz, prepare
diyebilirsiniz. Tamam mı? Burada da
yapacağımız hareket şu. Şuraları da
aslında daha custom olarak ayırabilirim
de benim buradaki yapmak istediğim
hareket şu arkadaşlar. Ben eee platform
spesifik olarak diyeceğim ki final class
mesela şuraya final class web e platform
initializer diyeceğim. Bir tane de
mesela final class. İşte mobile
diyeceğim şu anlık genel olarak. Çünkü
bizim projelerimiz artık web mobile
olarak kullanılıyor ki mobile'ı da bu
arada çok sık kullanıyoruz. Bunları
buraya koyacağız. Bunları neden
koyuyoruz? Bazen web hfunda web
logiklerini yapmanız gereken kısımlar
oluyor. Şunu da platform initializer
olarak şuraya alayım. Platform init
init
iner
dedim. Şöyle bunu yazarken
tedirginliklük duyuyorum ya.
Şimdi şuraya aldım.
Buraya attım. Tamam mı? Bu özellikle
bunları yaptığımızın o karmaşıklıklarda
burası daha iyi oturacak. Ama buradaki
amaç o web mobil klasındaki yapacağımız
kısımları böyle if webs şuyse değil
aslında global bir şekilde mesela burası
başladıktan sonra bu runımı verdim ben.
Bu run doğru bir şekilde çalıştı
diyelim. Bu run çalışırken de ben
diyorum ki aslında benim bu klassımın
kendi içerisinde benden bir tane
platform initializer isteyecek. Bunu
unit eden kişi class neyse kendisi
kullansın bana döndürsün. Hatta bunu
istersem şu anlık ben şey de
yapabilirim. Derim ki mesela şurada
şurada İngilizce değil mi klavyem benim?
Heh. Şunu da şöyle yapabilirim sayın
dostlar. Late final derim. Bu set olacak
derim. Buraya da mesela derim ki mesela
web. Buraya da hani ben kendim yazarım
bu koşulu. Şu an K webse diye bir koşulu
atarım. Buraya entegre ederim. Burada
unutmamanız gereken ekstra bir bilgi.
Diyelim ki siz web ve mobili daha
spesifik olarak bir initializer
yapıyorsunuz. Mesela web'de ben bir tane
gideceğim bir JavaScript classıyile
alakalı bir logciğim var, bir şeylerim
var. Yani web indesi kullanıyorum. Mobil
mobil io kullanıyor. Bu noktada o zaman
bir conditional import yapıp şurada
import ona da şey neydi unuttum bak
adını. Onu bir yine bir tabir vardı
unutuyorum. Yukarı yani aslında en üstte
if seviyesini import ederken şurada
şurada yazdığım importlarda ifadel
seviyesinde dart html işte is if deyip
şurada dart html falan filan yazdığımız
bir kodumuz var burada buna göre class
import edebiliyoruz onunla da alakalı
ilerl konuşuruz onu verip burayı
bağlayabiliriz tamam burayı yaptım ben
artık şurada prepare diyorum buradaki
ben buraya başlarken diyorum ki önce git
platform inşilclarını prepare et
sonrasında mesela bunu da ayırabil ama
şu anlık yeterli olacaktır. Ben kendi
Firebage initializerımı burada call
ediyorum mesela. Eee, sonra mesela benim
neyim var burada? Main dart'tan
alacağım. Mesela şu şuradaki kodların
hepsini şuradan çıkartıyorum artık.
Çünkü diyorum ki hocam sizin yeriniz
burası değil. En azından ben bu
initializer'ı burada yapacaksam bunları
bu tarafa alıyorum. Tamam mı? Hatta
burada ne yapmışız mesela? O main
dart'ın içerisinde işte şöyle bir remote
config analizasyonu yapmıştım mesela ve
bunlar da sanırım şuralarda bir şekilde
setlenmiş falan filan bir şeyler olmuş.
Bunlar garip bir bağlama olmuş. Şöyle
şunları hatta direkt şu ya bir kere bir
de bu arada tabii bunu da söylemekte
fayda var. O e kodlarını üretirken çok
görüyorum. İşte böyle sınıf dışı şeyler
yani sınıfın üstünde klassların dışında
kullanılan metotlar vesaire arkadaşlar
bunlar hep bu objektörent dillerde
olması gereken yani olmaması gereken
şeyler yani bunlar çünkü böyle statik
olarak yerden mesela bunu buraya
koyuyorsun her yerden
eriştirebiliyorsun. No abi bu ihtiyacı
olan erişmeli. İhtiyacı olan yerden
erişmeli ve kontrollü erişmeli. Bunu her
zaman yapın bu arada o kodlar generate
olurken çünkü bunda genelde de gözden
kaçıyor. Gözden kaçtığı zaman da burası
uçuyor. Şimdi mesela burada bir işlem
yapılmış. Bu remote config'le alakalı.
Burada da şu an tabii bu kodun çok
detayına girmeden aslında burada bir
tane Firebase diye bir tane klasörümüzü
yapıp hemen altına buraya eee mesela
remote
Firebase deyip şöyle custom
remote deyip mesela remote config deyip
dostlar şuraya mesela şu anlık şunu
attım buraya buraya da geldim final
class dedim yine custom remote configi
verdim. Bunu da yine abstract class
yapıp aslında instance'lara vermekte
sıkıntı yok. Burayı da verebilirsiniz
ama şu anlık şöyle yapalım. Şuraya
Firebase Remot confii de verdim. Ya bu
analitiği de aldı da içine. Çok önemli
değil. Şunları da vermiş olum. Buraya
setlerini vermiş oldum. Şu kısımda model
olacak. Bunun yeri ayrı zaten. Şu an
konuşmuyorum ben. Sonuçta günün sonunda
şu eee benim şuradaki aslında şöyle
custom yazdığım şeylerin hepsini şuradan
siliyorum. Custom removecig. Initializ
diyorum. Hatta diyorum ki şayet bu sınıf
aslında burada set edebilirim. Bu sayede
late'i böyle yalnız bırakmayacağım. En
sevmediğim şey böyle kalması. Mesela bir
instance hiç kullanılmayacaksa bir daha
ve bir kere setlenecek ve değişmiyorsa
muhakkak late final'da bunu doğru
şekilde yönetmekte fayda var. Ardından
mesela burada yönetimimi sağladım.
Instance'larımı intialize ettim. Burası
da hani e kullanımımı da sağladım
diyelim. Her şey hazır. Şunlar dediğim
gibi sonranın konusu. Burası benim için
temiz bir şekilde gelmiş oldu. Şurada
custom remote config nokta geldi.
Gereksiz commandleri de sildim.
Initializer'ım benim için hazır. Ben app
initializer içerisinde prepare deyip
logiclerimi yönetiyorum. Hatta
isterseniz bir tane de ileriye götürüp
şunları da hocam bunlar anlık olarak
olsun biz çok beklemeyelim bu işlemleri
deyip şöyle feature weight diyerek de
arkadaşlar aslında bunları eee aynı anda
paralel olarak istek olarak
yollayabilirsiniz. Tabii bu bazı
durumlarda gerek eee zorluyor ama
bozulabilir. E ihtiyaç olabilir. Mesela
bu arada mesela şunu en güzel benim
sevdiğim örnek picker mesela genelde
picker initialize kodları yazıyoruz.
Picker'ın bazı kodları var vesaire.
Mesela mobilde var iod'dan geliyor
web'de. Bunları buraya koymak lazım.
Şimdi mesela main dart tamam benim için.
En azından main dart'te bu şu halden
aldım ben main dart'ı. Şunu sildim.
Bunları sildim. Bundan sonra yine
burası. Ha şu an Myep'i silmeyelim. Mayi
de oradan alacağız bu arada. Şunu da
aldım. Mayp'i de buradan sileceğim.
Şimdi buraya sadece benim demem gereken
şuraya öncelikle hatta bunu da
sileceğim. Şu app inizer.
Run'ı vereceğim. Sonra bir de prepil
vereceğim. Şurası hop uçtu. Sonrasından
şunlar geldi yerine. Şurada gereksiz
şeyleri şuradan yine yanlış mı yazmışız?
Hangisini yazmışım?
Bak.
Init product.
Şunu yanlış yazmışız.
Init
initial initializ. Ha bu yok. Tamam
oturdu. Tak diye geldi bu da. Okey.
Şimdi burada bizim yapacağımız hareket
şu arkadaşlar. Sadece mesela my app diye
bir şey var ya bu da önemli. Mesela
genelde projelerde çok sık gördüğümüz
bir şey oluyor. Şu neymiş ya mesela bu
bak görüyor musunuz? Şimdi bu normalde
bu analit buradan erişmiş. Bunu da ref
factoring gününü yapacağız ama biz
mesela custom bu remote config'ta
yaptığımız instance üzerinden aslında
bunu şuna çevirebilirim daha güzel olur.
Şunu geldim zaten o statik. Şunları
verdim. Hop. Bunları verdim. Şunların
lateini kaldırdım. Şunu geldim. Statik
olarak statik olarak şuraya şey
yapacağım. Hop. Bunlar zaten bana geldi.
Burada custom config nokta. Şuraya bir
tane de static instance deyip
instance deyip şöyle
custom config instance'ını verip buraya
arkadaşlar şuradan kapatırsam da bir
birinin bundan türetmesini engellersem
şurayı da çevirelim.
Bu sayede burası temiz bir şekilde benle
olur. Mesela burada da şu anlık hani
bunları bu şekilde set ettim varsayın.
Bunların üzerine çalışacağız yine. Yani
hatalar gitsin diye.
Şunları şu anlık yapalım.
Hop.
Tamam.
Bak remote bir de yani zaten burada en
önemli şey arkadaşlar onun da farkında
olun. Hiçbir zaman için third party bir
library tak diye projeye eklemeyin. Yani
muhakkak önünde benim yaptığım gibi bu
custom must custom must bir şekilde bir
isimlendirme yapıp şey yapın. Eee önüne
bir layer yazın. Neden? Mesela ben bu
custom remote config güzel oldu ama
burada mesela bir farklı ne
yapabilirdim? Bu custom remote confi
ayırsaydım yarın remote confi
değiştirmek istediğimde direkt o
abstraction sayesinde as basit bir
strateji yaklaşımıyla işte eee ben bu
paterni aslında basket pakete çok rahat
evirebilirdim. Şu an yine de en azından
bir yerden yönettiğim için sadece bunu
değiştirsem en azından dışarıdakiler
anlamaz şeklinde ilerleyebilirim. Ama
yine remote config instance'ı benim
dışarı vermemem lazım. Benim ne yapmam
lazım? Bakıldığında remote configin
benim kendi parametrelerimi aacağım.
Mesela set logger hani çok detaym
logger'ı ole vermeyeceğim. Ben logger
vereceğim ekran öyle kullanacak gibi. Ya
bunları bilin ki eğer kodlarınıza
bunları bol bol yazdırın. Şimdi tamam
main dart tamam arkadaşlar. Benim için
main dart'tta temel aksiyonlar tamam.
Burada sadece bir fazla olarak şunu da
yapmakta fayda var. Onu sadece
söyleyeyim size. Mesela bu my appi. Ya
buradan çıkarmak önemli. Ben bunu da
burada tavsiye ediyorum bu arada. Yani
isterseniz burada sub featur'larınızda
gelip bir tane main diye oluşturup e
main app demekte fayda var. Çünkü bu
main app'in de içerisinde zamanla bazı
logicler geliyor. Bu bazı logicleri de
burada en azından yönetmek eee bunları
bunun yerini bilmek bunda, eee şöyle
diyeyim, main app diyeyim buna. Eee
önemli olacak zamanla. Ondan dolayı
burnu bu tarafa atmakta bir zarar
görmüyorum şu anlık. Ha bunu bu arada
private da yapabilirsiniz. Part part
part part of deyip ama şu an yine bence
o da buranın başlığı değil. Onu da
ilerleyen zamanda şöyle kullanıyor
olacağız. Bu da benim için hazır. Bunu
da oluşturduk. Burada sadece bir basit
bir konumuz daha var arkadaşlar. Şimdi
diyelim ki böyle projeye başladınız ve
projede bir şey daha detay girmek
istiyorsunuz. O detayda da yapmanız
gereken hareket basit bir şekilde
aslında konfigürasyon. Bu konfigürasyonu
mobille ve flutter tarafında biz aslında
flavorlarla yapıyoruz ama aslında son
zaman ya yakın çok uzun zamandır var
aslında da bu dark define bu işi yapmak
biraz daha bizim elimizi kolaylaştırıyor
ve yönetebilir durumda oluyoruz. Ne
yapıyoruz biz basitçe? Buraya geliyoruz.
Product'ımızın altında package'lerimizde
utlerimiz de olabilir. Core katmanımız
burada logiclerimizi yönettiğimiz yer
olarak da olabilir burada bizim. Çünkü
burası bir aslında artık eee manager
katmanımız diyelim buna. Önemli değil
yani. Util katmanı da olur bu arada.
Buna bir tane ben diyorum ki bir tane
flavor diyeyim şu anlık ismine veya
environment diyeyim.
Environment diyeyim bunun içerisine ve
ben buraya gelip bir tane application
işte ben ona flavor demişim şurada da o
çok önemli değil yani. Flavor olsun şu
an adı. Bunu sonra düzeltiriz. Ben bu
flavor'daki direkt şu kodu şuraya
alayım. Buradaki yaptığımız hareket şu
arkadaşlar aslında basitçe.
Bu ne yapmış? Şuraya şunları sil abi.
E bu ne yapmış? Bir saniye.
Heh, tamam sildi, uçtu. Tamam. Benim bir
iki tane aslında envirment'ım var. Bu
environment'ımın içerisinden datayı
okuyup ekrana veriyorum. Burada ben şu
şekilde aslında doğrudan şuraya da bu
value'u da almasaydım şöyle olacaktı
aslında. Final diyecektim. Ben kendim
bunu aslında şu şekilde okuyabiliyorum.
E environment
e string from environment dedim. Burayı
bu şekilde getirdim. Şöyle yapayım. Heh.
Ama yok. Bunu kullanacağız zaten
aşağıda.
Şöyle yapacağız. Value'ya gerek yok.
Hatta direkt buraya get yapacağım bunu.
Hop.
Current diyeceğim. Flavor diyeceğim.
Current diyeceğim. Current'ı aldı.
Envement'la setledi. Buraya getirdi.
Şimdi buradaki amacımızsa adam yani
client siz başladığınızda basit de olsa
BM yönetimini bu şekilde yapıp projenin
özellikle security anlamında da runtime
setiğiniz için daha avantajlı bir hale
gelmiş olursunuz. Burada sadece yine
dikkat etmeniz gereken buraya bir tane
modeller oluşturacağımız zamana geldik
diyelim. Modellerin içerisinde bir tane
de constant diye bir
constantlarımız olacak. Ben ayırıyorum.
Hani ayırmasak da olur ama yine de ben
koyayım şuraya. Mesela application
constant veya burada biz eee string eee
en environment
const yani constant diyeyim şuraya. Bunu
verin. Tamam mı? Buradaki amacımız da
yine bir tane şöyle string constant
oluşturmak. Bunu şöyle de yapabilirim.
Şu şekilde yapayım. Mesela bunun
içerisinde ben şeyleri tutabilirim. Eee
benim nelerim var mesela? Hangi
key'lerim var? Eee, string mesela şey
şuradan alacağım.
Flavor
ya doğrudan o string'i de verebilirim de
ben burada şey olarak yanıtıyorum. Hani
K'leri de burada ayırıyorum mesela
diyelim. Flavor olarak yaptım. Neden?
Çünkü ben buraya geldiğimde şurada elle
ben yine set etmek istemiyorum. Şunun
içerisini de buradan almak istiyorum. He
bunu da doğrudan orada şey yapabilirdim
de ama şunun ismi yanlış oldu.
Eee ename edelim. Env
romant.
Tamam. Şimdi burada sadece mesela bunu
yaptınız. Hop burayı bağladınız. Şunları
da şunu da bağlayayım.
Tamam burayı bağladım. Bu da bizim
aslında şu an için yine basitçe bu tarz
projelerde bir konfigürasyon yapmamızı
anlamak açısından önemli. Burada sadece
bir fazla yapmanız gereken son olarak da
konfigürasyonu ya Flutter run'ına
vereceksiniz ya da burada benim şu an
size atacağım şuradaki yine bir basit
bir run koduyla vereceksiniz. Yani siz
proje başlarken burada bakın bu otomatik
olarak buraya gelmiş olacak. Bu da çok
önemli. Özellikle coding yaparken
konfigürasyonlarınızı burada setmeye
başlarsanız en azından doğru bir şekilde
ilerletirsiniz kısmı. işte dark define
belli başlık parametreleri veya ya da
işte flavor propertisini set
edeceksiniz. Mesela şurada apik demiş ya
bu apik olmayacak. Şurası flavor olacak
gibi. Bu şekilde buradan setlerimizi de
yapıp aslında biz konfigürasyonun ve
projenin eee yönetimini bağlamış
olacağız. He biraz daha mobile basited
giderseniz flavor set ettirebilirsiniz.
Yani flavor ayarları var ama global bir
projede web yaptığınızda flavor olmadığı
için o zaman otomatik olarak ya web'de
environment'tan oku, Flavor'ı buradan
oku ya da Flavor'ı komple buradan
yöneteceksiniz. Ama Mobilin Flavor'ı
zaten başka bir konsept. Oranın başlığı
değil. Or da artık diğerinde arkadaşlar
diğer içerikte görüşürüz. Şimdilik
burayı yapmış olduk diyelim. Hatta buna
da şeyion diyeceğim ama eee niye işim
var benim?
4 desem şöyle eşleşir mi acaba?
Eşleşmeli.
Tamam comitledim.
Yoksa bile pieri oradan bağlarız.
Şöyle PR'ımı açayım
yine arkadaşlar PR'den erişebilirsiniz.
Şurada
eee şuraları verdim. Assign ettim
kendime. Enhanment dedim. Bunu da
buradan alayım. Issun içinde yoksa
issunun içerisine de atmış olayım. Ha
geldi dediğim gibi. Tamam. Süper. Eee bu
içeriklik de bu kadar arkadaşlar. Eee
devam edeceğiz yine Masterclass'a.
Kendinize iyi bakın. Görüşmek üzere.